[Music]
in a typical hero's journey the
protagonist set sight on an adventure
undergoes great change and returns and
triumphs to their point of origin but in
the Irish genre of myth known as octree
the journey to the other world ends in a
point of no return while there are many
different versions of the Otherworld in
Irish mythology the most well-known
example occurs in the story of oshi
Oshin was the son of Finn McCool the
leader of a group of pagan warriors
known as the fina as Oshin rode with his
companions one day he was visited by the
immortal princess named the two fell
instantly in love and Eve pulled Oshin
onto her white horse and rode with him
to the edge of the Irish Sea as they
made for the horizon the riders sunk
into a golden haze they came to the
shores of the gleaming kingdom called
Tiernan oak this was the home of the -
her date and all the people who ruled
ancient Ireland long before oh she was
time from the point of his arrival or
Sheen's every need was met he married an
even a grand ceremony and was welcomed
into her family when he wished to hear
music his ears filled with bewitching
tones when he homered golden plates
appeared laden with fragrant food he
admired scenes of great beauty in colors
that he had no name for all around him
the land and the people existed in a
state of unmoving perfection
but what Oshin didn't know was that
Tiernan oak was the land of youth in
which time stood still and the people
never aged in his new home or sheen
continued to hunt and explore as he had
in Ireland but in the land of youth he
possessed a strange new invincibility at
the end of each day of adventuring
machines wounds magically healed
themselves as he slept in the absorbs
although glory and pleasure came easily
to Oshima in the land of youth he missed
the fina and the adventures they had in
ireland after three years in Tiernan oak
he was struck by a deep yearning for
home before he embarked on his journey
back Nev warned him that he must not
alight from his horse to touch the earth
with his own feet
when Oshin reached the shores of Ireland
it felt as if a shadow had fallen over
the world on the hill where his father's
palace lay he saw only a ruin strewn
with weeds his calls for his friends and
family echoed from derelict walls
horrified ocean road until he came upon
a group of peasants working in the
fields they were struggling to remove a
boulder from their land and forgetting
Neves warning while she left from his
horse and rolled it away with his
superhuman strength
the crowds cheers soon turned into
shrieks in place of the youth was an old
man whose beard swept the ground on
whose legs buckled under him he cried
out for Finn and the fina but the people
only recognized these names from the
distant past of 300 years before time
had betrayed Oshin and his return to
mortal lands had aged him irreversibly
throughout Irish folklore sightings of
the land of youth have been reported in
the depths of wells on the brink of the
horizon or in the gloom of caves but
those who know the tale of Oshin tell of
another vision that of a shining
princess carried upon the distant waves
by a white worse still hoping for the
return of her doomed love
[Music]
if you enjoyed this lesson please
consider supporting Ted's nonprofit
mission on patreon.com slash Ted ed
[Music]